when did you start like regularly
smoking weed um since I was like Kenya
though the whole time we were fighting
you were regular smoking weed well you
know when your kid your mother gives you
liquor and marijuana for you make you
think that you're gonna go to sleep or
something yeah really yeah
that never happened in my house no yeah
damn that's that's harsh liquor and
marijuana see if you go to sleep
yeah it didn't work I don't think so do
you uh what what what benefits you get
out of marijuana like what does it do
for you hey man if I didn't not have a
bad day yeah I'm really moody guy
without it and it's just um he smoothes
me out so they think I'm a whole
different person on top of my game I'm
ballin
yeah I feel the same way sometimes makes
me nicer yeah yeah calms me down
do you like Who I am why I smoke you
know I mean when I'm when I weed I don't
think like Who I am sometimes that's
just the real yeah yeah I don't like
that guy want to get away from that guy
well you know I was talking to Michael
Irvin once he was explaining to me that
when children grow up in high stress
environments that their genes are wired
to have a propensity towards violence
that their norm if it's normal it's
around them all the time when they're
when they're growing up and when they're
in the womb yeah I agree
when the mothers under extreme stress if
they live in a bad neighborhood and it's
it's hard for some people like yourself
that did grow up in an environment like
that to ever reach where you're at right
now just a place of peace and if you can
do that through marijuana or whatever it
is yoga meditation whatever it whatever
you do to get there like we should be
happy that you can get there that's what
we don't listen I'm so grateful that um
I embarked on this you know I've never
been a person to this it's magnitude
that this kind of relaxation is enjoying
my time with you I was very up tighter
than anything I was very uncomfortable
with myself did you feel any better
after you worked out when you were young
like that absolutely my works out um you
know what um the best thing that
happened to me that retired from boxing
with me working out Amiga and I was so
intense with this my whole my whole
objective was hurting people and
wouldn't be the best of my
took over and I'm lying - I'm the best
ever live in all this [ __ ] and the
other with my partner Rob Hickman I
happened to embark on this come across
this thing called the toad and he
familiar with the toad
yeah well you're talking about his five
methoxy bar that fit right there yeah
yeah and I came across that and I smoked
this song I don't know this medicine
drug whatever you want to call it and
I've never been the same I look at life
different I look at people differently
and the experiments I can't even express
really it's almost like dying and being
real reborn yeah I had the exact same
experience that's what it felt like to
me to like you stop existing the five
meth oxys uh there's - tell me what's
the deal with it
five-minute oxys produced by your brain
but what it is is it's DMT with an
oxygen molecule attached to it there's a
regular DMT is N and dimethyltryptamine
and then five methoxy dimethyltryptamine
DMT with like a very there's a very
subtle change to the molecule and that
subtle change for some reason takes away
the visuals you've done regular DMT -
right yes
regular DMT is rich with visuals very
strained bright colorful impossible
describe visuals if and yes if
inconceivable inconceivable is best way
but I tried to explain it to some people
my wife and I it's just I don't have the
words to explain it that's exactly what
I always say I've done a terrible job
explaining it to everybody every time
I've tried it just doesn't work but all
those things they give you perspective
almost like you're dying you give you
you're submissive you're humble you know
you're vulnerable but you're invincible
still in all you know this isn't that
weird feeling but you feel like you're
part of the universe when you're
separate from your ego you realize this
whole thing you're a part of this whole
thing and this whole thing is and
stoppable it's just it's a gigantic huge
all-encompassing almost like a living
thing I know John this is what I also
realized to have to go into
you realize how insignificant you are
sometimes without the ego yes you know
yeah that's why you're not really much
that you really thought you were yeah
you are and you aren't obviously you are
in everyday life I mean you go places
you have a dramatic effect on people you
mean a lot you mean a lot to those
people that you run into you mean a lot
to the people that you love and that
love you but we all do and when the no
ones stand no it's all it's all relative
no one no one is irreplaceable but
everyone is special to someone or
something and at least to themselves but
we're all the same we're all part of
this weird crazy gigantic organism
that's the human race